こんにちはドクターはじめな私今日も歯医者に行ってきたんですけども歯を抜いてき
ました
すごい大量の麻酔を打たれあを抜かれた時守護口が出来ました
もう再販のことばっかり痛かったり苦しかったりでの僕の頭なんかもう9割5分花ほど
しかなくてあんなことばっかり考えていたらこちらが思い浮かんできました
マニュアルにパニックまぢさんの歯をしていくんですけどどれカオスちゃうとガブッと
買われるっていうを張って大事なのに歯で遊ぶというなんとも不謹慎なゲームでござい
ます大事にしていきたいところだが
は
不謹慎です許せませんどれか乙葉顔グラしてスーパーつって指を買われてしまいます
それはそうですよ
貼って大事ですもんまあいいなぁそれ全部入っ planned だろうセラミックか
おやつで人工的な方から娘になることもないんだろうな
いいな
なったこうやってセットしますと木の葉のどれかを押すトラブって買われます
まあ
わーもう1回と言いましょうそう
だった
th
の
o 5 o
完全にバスはランだめなんですよ今多くばでしたよね
北への反応したところこれですねでもを開けココスと思い解雇こうしてはならないん
ですよ
つまりランダムでが振ってくる場所が変わっています
ここで私は思えてきましたこれ電池不要のおもちゃなんですよ電池不要のを持つ集まり
この中に何かそういうなかコンピューターとか何も搭載されてない普通のお茶なんです
けども
どうやってこれなんだ分に駄目って変われる葉を移動させているのがすごい気になっ
ちゃいまして何か法則性があるのかなと私は思いました
分かりませんだでデンソーも使っていないコンピュータ的なものが入ってい
ないこの状況がでランダムにするってないけどなんかこう
この価値がつかつか地の時になる歯車た方適当に噛み合ってこれは何な女ではなく一定
の法則で love ってなる歯が決まっている
そういうことではないでしょうかあーってなるとも芝に間にパニックのが打ってので
法則性を見抜いた私はたくさんの女の子との控えをしている時には邪魔にパニックで先
にかまれた人が服を脱ぎ絵みたいなゲームをするとほぼ100%の確率で全員どんなの
交通課にできるそんな夢のあるは2分にパニックゲームでできるという理由だけで早速
法則性を見抜いていきましょう
ではエコ全部で123456789中全部で刃は10個ありますねいえばいいかに行き
ます
怖い怖い
フォアう
あ
右から4番目えー右44
虫周りに間に行きます
あ左に3回目今度にランダムだったらすごい抜いてやるんだろうねぇ
誇りやすいように半に番号っていきましょうはい分かりやすい医療に端に番号を打って
いきました
だんだんの数学濃くなってきましたね4回目いきます
こえーまだ鳳雛か皆
2回連続とかなったら結構難しいですよ
あ多分1234ぐらいだと思うんです次
やっぱりなんとなくわかるつなんとなくなんとなくわかりますね次は多分456あかり
あーあやっぱりレッツ気が多分7が地球ぐらいのですよ
あれっええっさあ
a まずどういう法則なんかねさんとば c くらいのイメージがちょっと待ってきた
んですよね今8だったら t 91
次1です多分
組んだん
ん7890くらいです7
パチッ ok j a 6たブログです
a 5
は難しいなこれはんねちょっと偶然なのか今たことと数少ないんで偶然かわかんないん
ですけども前がぶりされた葉の左側に1個か2個か3個過剰子連れてる間になる可能性
がすごい高いです
基本的にさんが黒当たるとこっちがいない可能性は結構低い
こっち側の行くことができないことに行くさんことで見ることだけど感じが高いって
ほしい
今子だったら多分67月がたりこっちがだと思うんですよ
[音楽]
ほらんぱちゅだと言いま
でまぁ勝ちだったんで次は中ずーっとかな
第123
4かな永久上一篇8だんっ
でも入り込んレッドこっちだった宇宙の法則が乱れたんです
どういう作りなのをエッグいいじゃん女でがせねーよ
あっはい
でまた8やばい8が80されるよくなっている
同じカフェでまたカッツはないよ
んさすがにはカラーでもね
またに多いパターンとしてはやっぱりがクリされた
3個左の可能性は結構高いに息を統計的に見てもへ水6だったから次では初ですね89
ぐらいの可能性
おほらねー
[音楽]
今8だったらて20
大待ってでは言ってるきてる
10た次日産モコ2で過労寒いんだなぁ
a 3
やーわからんよこの前の端辺りは結構出たら次こっちが2個多くみたいな感じに変わっ
ている気がします
今読んだったからスギロックとかです多分このほらほらほらほら方法
2月8ラン
もう待ってまず当たってるんじゃ
ん
てられた時中なんだろうな大待って
法則が見いだしているただこっから側からこっからはからさっき4だったから4かな
なのであなたの7大洞ねー
全卵のにここずれるから多摩キュート金津
あれ
say
[拍手]
[音楽]
me
バッハ
はい重機でちょっと100回ぐらい検証してみたんですけどもわっかーる幼児分かり
ません
たその曖昧な状態は決してあの理論だけて言えることではないので
だから紅白立した検証結果にはならなかったんですけども
4っぽいよいい音が出ると次僕の可能性が高くて録画で一つに髪になる可能性が高くて
8がれる月下旬での可能性のたタイプ
次はのアーム聞くこの左側にそれで行くことが多いですでタグやその歯車の歯の数が
例えば
13個の歯車と重要この歯車があるとこうなんか
ランダムになっちゃったりするからある程度の規則性はあるもののすごいたの複雑な
中身になってるんじゃないかなと思います
わかんないわかんないわかんない山もこれ難しいなと
分わからない歯車の活動を受ければほど多分より複雑なんでタバコの100回した
ところでなかなかで法則性を見いだすのは難しいかなと思いました
とりあえずですねお前は虫歯になるのか羨ましいなきゃー